toutefois ils sont là c'est le
chroniqueur que vous aimez que vous
préférez ils sont autour de la table
ils sont là ils sont chauds non par les
médias n'ont parlé de tout ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui
attention on va démarrer par là mon ami
salut match et rip au micro c'est parti
comment tu t'appelles alicia comment tu
est intitulé alice à alicia tu as quel
âge 17 1 10 17e vie qui tue fêtait pas à
l'école à san ou nas et pas jean-luc
lahaye qui présente l'émission là à la
mi temps quelle classe et pas trop bonne
micro dans la mine elle termine à quoi m
gsm j ai maintenant il ya des terminales
on les comprend pas mon cas à l'époque
tu avais des terminales l littéraire gay
est sûre typique maintenant ouais je
suis en terminale s aiment dbg société
médicale des beaux gosses ont fleuri
passé un truc de ouf
maintenant tu as des terminales où as tu
sais pas tu comprends pas que ça veut
dire quoi tu fais quoi
alors bon bah merci d'être là c'est qui
c'est quoi
merci tu es content d'être là oui super
content c'est vrai ma boîte et kamel
bonjour bonsoir saluer on se régale et
on dirait valérie bénaïm mais en
dordogne
j'aime bien comment tu t'appelles
mathieu laura laura oui j'aime bien
alors on aime bien le cui apparemment
l'eau alors et je peux demander à tout
le monde et jeune tu as quel âge 35 ans
35 ans qu'est ce tu fais dans la vie
assistant commercial dans quoi dans une
société de courtage en prêts immobiliers
l on voit qu'elle est sûre d'elle elle
elle fait cette télé mais il se dit je
vais pas rester longtemps dans la
société c'est le cas qu'un de remarques
je me barre direct je me barre direct en
télé quoi je suis très heureux d'être là
c'est vrai que ça fait très longtemps
que je vous rencontrer c'est pas vrai et
participe à l'émission et je vous
retrouverai très con dans le troupeau à
la tv
[Applaudissements]
la tente devant tant d où toi
sentimentalement toi alors je suis marié
et maria wifi avec we s'intitule
celui-ci greg greg toute allure le coni
permien à moins bien sûr greg david gray
qui fait quoi lui lui il a une société
dans le bâtiment lui il a une société
dans la durée une pub lui la société
dans le bâtiment car si elle est basse
au micro la la la la la
on dirait le frère de maxime ghenim vois
tu te dis tu saches là ça a aidé son
prénom mon frère on dirait qu'il me dit
kemal otto rahn il est tout fier de dire
son prénom ce choc
tu fais quoi dans la vie mon gars
troisième année en journalisme j'étais
alors t'as quel âge j'ai 21 ans 21 en
troisième année oui mes frères mois 21
ans 83e tout court jetez pas y avait pas
d'année quoi et alors atteignent
sciences et arts oui non plus lui qui
lance paradis où elle allait à l'école
tu as ta mort si elle est là elle est la
wic clc héloïse un lâche le héros
s'appelle colline en colline
bah écoutes je suis content que ça se
passe bien entre vous parce que je sais
qu'elles n'étaient pas chaudes surtout
au début
je voulais vraiment vous remercier parce
que chaque soir vous attend à la télé on
rigole et tout ça mais vous avez vu
sacha il a pris le micro on dirait qu'il
va faire du bruit vacances pas se croire
madame
salut ma chérie alors on est venu
finalement je suis venu de la part d'une
jeune ami ce qui vous connaît très bien
d'accord et je voudrais faire un hommage
à un petit garçon qui s'appelle enzo
d'accord et handicapées
bien qu'ils habitent à marseille vont
lui faire un gros bisou voilà ils
avaient entre deux lattes raison
d'accords nous regarde la enzo
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas parce que j'ai
c'était ça s'est fait tellement vite je
ne vais pas passer à la tv j'ai promis à
sa maman j'ai promis à sa maman bon je
sais qu'on doit pas demander des choses
mais j'aimerais bien vous voir un jour
pour demander quelque chose pour ce
petit enzo tu me donneras tu me donneras
tu me donneras ce petit chose est sûre
quand tu t'appelles ma chérie parce
qu'on avait racheté alors moi je suis la
nounou chez nous nous vous de la part
d'une journaliste qui travaille fou et
je travaille pour les convois savoir qui
tu es c'est pas nous embrouiller parce
que c'est pas clair la marque ne veut
pas dire qu'ils allaient en fait s'est
agacé le way le mec les vidéos de barils
non non nous on est je suis là nous nous
inquiète un peu longuette les nounous
c'est au nom de famille voilà odette
nounou très bien rôle alors au la bombe
atomique propos popopo propos comment
s'intitule tu ophélie ont fait lire l
sané ciani
ça va être j'aime bien au final fait que
des bosses comment je m'appelle au
finish c'est un stage sur un stage
m'appelle au fait t'es cardiaque ouais
ça va tu arrêtes toi je fais quoi dans
la vie je travaille en parfumerie
non s'ils n'oublient pas de travail chez
ses maîtres à quoi un chien en ce moment
je suis au chômage
non c'est pas vrai ouais proyas plus
parfaite classe pour moi pour l'instant
pas d'accord ces visites est pas
d'ailleurs t'as quel âge 24 ans tuée
fiancée marié il angers personnes alors
il y à lui qui va bientôt se réveiller
il est en cours de libération d'accord
machine mais en tout cas merci d'être là
tu es content si fiat était content de
passer la première vous voyez vous voyez
un petit peu les moyens de l'émission
que ce qu'on a un micro pour une hausse
en personne j'adore maîtresse au mas
[Musique]
je dois y aller
m
en matière y d'abord comment tu
t'appelles marché mais quoi t'es pas il
ya eto'o mais pourquoi la peau va la
passer pâques est inquiète tu es toi tu
t'inquiètes je vais te mettre un
fauteuil se met tout ce que tu me
t'inquiète pas c'est pour moi ça nous
met bien sûr daniel d'apprentis chariot
sans toi maintenant qu'est ce tu fais
dans la vie mais je m'appelle rose je
suis à stoke maternelle j'adore tes très
sympathique en tout cas merci j'aime
bien ton nous j'adore compétition
paternel oui il a dû contente d'être là
oui dit tout j'habite à saint maur des
fossés
je connais très bien j'avais pécho une
meuf à la marine sacco tc mitoyen à côté
du marché
ouais je sais que je peux te dire que
quand tu faisais le marché tu repars tu
es sûrement se sauvant avec moi qu'avec
toi non célibataires sony bottes mon
anniversaire dimanche et bah écoute
alors apparemment je suis habité piano
pas de cadeau
on a vous l'avez bien sûr reconnu est
avec nous bien sûr le grand père m'a dit
comment ça va mon chéri comment tu très
bien mais pascal bats jo c'est pascal
qui rapide l1 qui vient de voir très
souvent parce qu'alors qu'il suffit dans
la vie toi je ne travaille plus pour le
moment
tu es plus barbie je travaille au cinéma
travaille dans le cinoche classé 7e à
roye ses directeurs de casting est
content d'être avec nous où vit toujours
très tôt avant de recevoir d'un amour il
est tout à fait souvent nous voir vous
avez freire cepa jour tu réalises aux
producteurs toi ennemi tout à l'heure je
vois en train de regarder et pas du tout
tu révises mon frère tu as ouvre toi
pascal tamo et ont pris je sais rien
à l'est derrière je sais là ça
d'ailleurs et est ce que tu as que tu as
quelque chose à dire à ton amoureux ça
bien sûr comment s'appelle esmeralda
j'adore quand elle danse et qu'elle met
encore un jour eh ouais esmeralda alors
je dirai ce que tu as quelque chose à
dire experts aldar ça fait combien de
temps que vous êtes ensemble ça fait un
an en fait on se connaît depuis l'âge de
14 ans non666 auditions des deux pays
bas tout à fait non c'est et réponse est
oui depuis l'âge de 14 ans il répond de
l'école et on a eu on a eu des vies on
sait on était amoureux que sur les bancs
de l'école
après la vie a fait chacun fait son
petit bout de chemin à quoi il ya quatre
ans s'est rencontré sur un
1 sciences sur le même banc non via via
via internet
non on s'est retrouvés non non non non
copains d'avant
et puis voilà et puis ça fait quatre ans
qu'on est ensemble quatre ans que
j'élève d'autant que j'ai retrouvé
quelques temps qu'elle me fait chavirer
cas tant qu elle me rend fier c'est
mignon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chose qui peut le faire
je suis content que tu es petite
déclaration mouiller
alors là c'est alors lui il est venu il
croyait vraiment qui était chroniqueur
de plus ils révisent et m'a dit qu'ils
révisent le conducteur et basile et truc
alors toi tu as
on est un petit peu en retard même on a
un petit peu c'est parce qu'on est en
retard la feria même pas dessus
on est comme on irait alors comment tu
t'habitues mois ces mots c'est patrick
ces lots sont guère qu'à une hésitation
quand tu lui demande son prénom
on dirait qu'il est en classe au tableau
tu as demandé un truc de ouf
et bien moi c'est pâtit quoi ça patrick
je crois que tu allais me sortir un
prénom tout genre mahmoud patrick nom
patrick tu fais quoi dans la vie mon
patrick je suis à la retraite bas et
mettez vous que le méthane qu'elles
retraite mes frères ta ta ta ta ta 28
louvel je sais bah ouais bah il faut que
tu te remettes un beau coup de sa boucle
tu viens nous voir souvent c'est très
content de te voir moi je suis bien
souvent avec pascal bon ça va tu étais
content à j'habite au jury argenté
argenteuil bataille de pain bah oui et
battra mais c'est prévu leurs bases ils
battraient baba très bien battus dès
leur nom aussi mon ami ok très bien mais
vous faites le tour d'accord en temps un
bon ça va mon chéri un petit message à
passer un petit truc à dire oui je
voudrais vous dire bonjour à ma femme
qui doit certainement me regarde et
comment sa femme corinne corinne auryn
et juliette j va arriver dans pas
longtemps
c'est qu'il est là ne voit pas
[Rires]
yoga
le mec qui parle comme si même chimie ou
coller c'est toute sa famille jour il
croise la mecque là maintenant bien sûr
juliette sa fille
il devait rentrer puis ça m'a mené par
une plaie qu'est ce que je te cyril tout
le monde te regarde la maison c'est pour
atteindre à bâcher son bras sport jugé t
et corinne fait d'accord il est juste
que les adjoints et l'on peut comprendre
elle est venue une fois mais à la pac
icher quoi pourquoi c'était pas il y
avait un cas stadiers à péter s'il est
il a déjà si oui tu es là déjà pas mal
c'est bien aller au combat ça comment il
soit ça va ou calme-toi et e.on va pas
reconnaissance taudou t'inquiète pas que
ça va bien se passer comment il
s'appelle celui-ci moi je m'appelle
anthony je viens de nîmes à retaper un
peu l'accent là frère à non vraiment je
parle comme ça mais j'adore c'est vrai
je m'appelle a retenu je viens de nîmes
qui s'appelle anthony ou antonie attend
chez vous vous dites anthony way est
chez moi on dit en tenue mais j'ai bien
hâte a vu comment ça passe mieux que tu
fais dans la vie antoni je suis étudiant
infirmier troisième année pas mal
et verrai avec mon chéri je suis venu
avec ma copine ma compagne à léo elle
est juste là au pavage à donne est
simple
cette belle j'ai fait un beau coup tous
les temps a vu comment elle s'appelle
marie camille marquer ma came as les
noms composés ça fait toujours beau ça
fait télé réalité aussi
ouais ouais moi non merci
tu es content d'être avec nous alors je
suis heureux c'est la deuxième fois que
je suis autour de cette table quoi
j'avais participé à la télé même l'été
non en jeu ah oui c'est pas tribu marché
ouais mais tu t'inquiètes pas là
aujourd'hui tu vas pas le gars me donne
les autres il ya des trucs ya cinq ans
on avait fait 280 mille téléspectateurs
s'étaient pas cesser cette époque où
beau merci mon chéri tu restes avec nous
ben oui merci
et elle est là regardez ça est très cool
alors comment tu t'appelles emilia
emilia j'aime bien tu as quel âge 18 ans
18 ans pile ça passe je sais toi t'as
17e mais c'est ma soeur c'est ta soeur
mais vous êtes donc de la même famille
oui mais que signifie cette mascarade
non c'est vrai mais vous êtes magnifique
tout les merci pour tout et la grande
soeur ouais mais on dirait que c'est de
la grande soeur on est tout le temps
mais non mais je sais je sais qu'on vous
dit tout le temps mais c'est ouf quoi tu
fais quoi toi chante prépa hec quoi
ouais prépa hec
oui prépa oui je suis en préparation h
le jour qu'en prépa chossy mettez une
tête c'est ouf
bah bravo merci enfin je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
je suis content oreilles